hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
la voiture va tourner tous mes tournées
tournée il faut qu'ils aient les trois
boules noires mais pour sortir d'accord
qui n'ont pas le droit gloire ça
continue à tourner mais on est on a dit
on n'en ferons les mondes là on a fait
la répète la personne et 21h30 dans la
boîte et je vous le dire mais on est
témoin de briques
oui oui mais on fait quoi des boules
noires vous les montre on fait quoi on
vous accueillera voulait lâcher oui à
vous essayer de rattraper contenir tous
les banques ont les arrêts de retour à
rattraper à canton tout retrait vaut
mieux montrer quand je le saurai de
toutes les façons jamais jarre tous ont
fait de la téloche
jean-luc ça va non parce que je sais que
vous aimez pas aimerait que je
redescends pourquoi voulu me suicider
avec lui j'ai jamais dis que j avais pas
eu la géniale or attention et me posez
vous les bonnes questions vous savez
vous aussi on sait qu'ils sont nos
habits bon c'est pas qu'ils sont nos
ennemis jolie attention c'est parti
pourrait fermer la porte aymeric on y va
lâcher la boule noire
en velay de chez à 51
[Applaudissements]
la piraterie pour le fait pour le fun et
bien voilà oui à briques au président du
faso n'est pas couché a mis là tu m'en
attendais mais vous préférez toutefois
vous pas qu air et briques vous préférez
deux femmes ont passé on n'est pas
couché l'aider
[Applaudissements]